nbc sports boston's tom curran back here
on the rich eisen show how are you tommy
how you doing big fella
well at least hoyer got some work last
night too huh i mean what a what a
lollapalooza what a belichick palooza do
your job palooza that was last night
philadelphia and the funny thing is you
know you're trying to process it and i
think they went 21 for 28 for 249
between cam and matt jones
and you're saying wow they looked
awesome but that really was hitting off
a t
as opposed to what we saw monday and
tuesday when they were playing against
derek barnett and fletcher cox and
darius slade none of those guys played
right so you don't want to be the turd
in the punch bowl like uh well who were
they playing against but uh well who are
they playing against
really what it comes down to
so
what do we make of this thing tom
because monday and tuesday how did they
look against the
uh
how do they look in the punch bowl
before the turds got in it
they
scuffled a little bit you know and i
don't want to go too far on the
defensive side of the ball but jalen
hurts was the best quarterback of the
group and he did a really great job
against the patriots defense you know
knocking passes into his tight end but
you know we're more
quarterback centric here for new england
and
mack was better than cam on monday
neither guy was good
on tuesday
with philly playing zone
in a lot of the
red zone situational stuff in seven on
seven and eleven on eleven and the
patriots not having johnny smith or
hunter henry it was it was a check down
brigade for both quarterbacks really
only one incompletion for camp
and one in completion which was a pick
for mack jones so
what i think the takeaway is
continues to be
mac jones is more efficient more
accurate more decisive than cam newton
on a day-in day-out basis
so it's gone on for a month did i hear
did i read something tom curran that
somebody on the eagles was heckling cam
as a check down king or something like
that during the tactics that's exactly
what he was labeled to check down king
and
kim said well you know stop playing zone
and give me soft spots in the zone and
i'll stop checking it down but i think
we saw last night for those who watch
the game
the reason
matt jones is going to
perhaps sooner rather than later emerge
as a patriot starter is his ability to
be accurate down the field and cam had a
few step up type throws because he was
going with his first offensive line
against the second and third defensive
lines in front sevens but he had the
opportunity to step up and throw
accurately in the mid-range but the
second week in a row you saw matt jones
throw a 40-yard plus pass
down field and hit somebody in the hands
both of them have been incomplete
but matt jones accuracy down the field
for a team that brought in aguilar in
kendrick born and hunter henry and
johnny smith there's a point which you
need to maximize those
resources you spent money on them you
want to use them one guy's better using
them than the other
tom curran nbc sports boston here on the
rich eisen show had you on uh early july
and you were talking about what you were
hearing and the raves from within the
patriot regime about mack jones picking
things up and being
uh a lot
closer to completion than potentially
other rookie quarterbacks might be
after their first mini camps what are
you hearing about his readiness
preparedness what people are saying
uh during training camp give me that one
very positive
feeling as if you know what we're seeing
and perceiving is is what the team is
seeing and perceiving as well you know
he's kind of eyeball the eyeball with
cam in many ways
many important ways
and that includes pre-snap post snap
accuracy and efficiency
the concern isn't and mike lombardi i
think articulated it on his podcast
do you want to think the roots a little
bit more
do you want to shelter him and that
which to me is
we can all reel off the examples patrick
mahomes tom brady aaron rodgers of guys
who were not thrown in the deep end
but justin herbert was thrown in the
deep end when tyrod taylor got his lung
punctured he did fine
the floor for mac jones is so high
that i don't think he needs to be wet
nursed through the early portion of the
season but we both know and you know
bill very well too
one interesting thing is look at all the
defensive and offensive coordinators
he's had over the years and the way he
resists
giving them a title
it's almost like well
he's gonna get he can't deal with the
criticism he won't be able to deal with
it why
what's the big deal
to me if you don't start matt jones at
the beginning of the year you're afraid
he can't take
and i think that's being a helicopter
parent
i i kind of agree with you tom because
how many times do we all
say that
you know alabama in the sec is as close
to the nfl as college football is going
to get and nick saban is as close to
belichick as you're going to get in
college football and now here he is in
professional football with belichick and
of course there is a learning curve but
i don't think
that there's anything that mac jones is
going to see or feel that he hasn't
already felt
in becoming a self-made man a kid who
used to be you know what 170 pounds
soaking wet now a mid first round draft
choice for the new england patriots the
first first-round drafted quarterback
since drew bledsoe i mean
i think he can take it the question is
is what is belichick's
process going to be i know you know you
know bill and you you mentioned about
how i've been around the guy and and
know him but i don't does anybody know
what his process
is of evaluation and thought is going to
be what he needs to see what you think
he's going to
go on with gut feel and how much that's
going to be part of the equation any
idea on that front tom i think he loves
this i bet being enigmatic and
having people get what bill gonna do he
has
no doubt embraced that element
of his brand that he has developed
so he loves it and he'll love the
interplay that we're going to engage in
over the next
however many days even though he might
outwardly not
seem to love it he's gonna love it i
can't wait i can't wait until these
idiots start asking me
um
but
there is a competitive advantage too if
you're brian flores and you have to keep
sitting here seeing cam newton play the
first quarter with all the ones
and it might happen again next week
against new york well then you have to
go into week one
preparing for
quarterback draws in read option
and a running quarterback as opposed to
you know
tom brady extra extra light who is going
to process and throw darts at your
defense so
there's a competitive advantage
that bill belichick might very well ring
every moment out of that he can and i
i can see how this is gonna go for about
another two or three weeks
so um
best guess
we're gonna go into week one and and
that lead up post labor day to week one
against the dolphins
he's gonna call those clouds close to
the vest right like we we won't yeah i
don't know there's no reason for him to
to make any move any decision any
announcement you can ask anything
a dumb question rich
teams don't have to announce
their starting quarterback
no
no they don't what's the upset unless
unless they they they want to give their
53 men and everyone else in the building
a little bit of guidance but they'll
know that by who takes the ones right
and anybody who breathes anything to
their their friends parents friend
agents and what have you and that gets
out they will have to fear the wrath
of belichick coming down from the mount
right like that's the way it'll probably
lead up to week one
that's true right here that's not a
practice
you know right after stretching we don't
see any
ones and twos
so it's not like we're gonna be
reporting on it we're gonna be trying to
start it out but
you know what's the upside of telling
tom curran who you think the starter is
going to be
up against your paycheck yeah
so how are you going to ask the question
tom you want me to be belichick you want
to practice no i don't think you need it
but i mean you know because we're gonna
yeah we're gonna see that i mean you
know
bill is uh
let's see let's do this okay think about
it don't ask a yes or no question
because you know he'll stick that one
aside the way to go the way to go is to
try and go nostalgia what did you do
back in that day and trying to get them
started i don't think that stuff applies
rich okay this is 2021 i'm not talking
about
you know phil simpson jeff hostage
all right we're all grasping at straws
tom
all right we're gonna go with uh
yeah
bill
clearly matt jones has appeared to be
the better thrower better decision maker
more accurate
if
you always do what's best for the team
and we know that that's the case in 2021
can you explain why cam newton would be
a better option to start than mack jones
well i mean we just you know evaluating
and
just
looking at the film and
you know
we'll i mean we'll just take a look at
it i mean that's your opinion i mean
we're we're looking at all that and i'm
sure we all value that tom i'm sure
everybody's dying to know exactly how
you see it
you don't need me to play bill you got
both ports
you've been part of this movie oh it's
going to be great and then you know you
know what sucks rich then you know
that whatever answer you get you stand
you run the risk of being of being the
lead story on twitter or wherever
that day are you mentally prepared for
that as a reporter
just sacrifice mike reese just to call
him out there
hide behind him hey mike i got a
question you should ask bill
i can do a wreath for you too hey uh
bill
we got uh
gotta start somebody on sunday
feeling like it could be mack
senbreer out there my very best friend
sent breer out there he's he's number
one in their hearts already anyway so
let's just send him out there
[Music]
this is great this is we're getting it
all from tom curran two drink minimum
tom curry has appeared here on the rich
island waitress um defensively it seems
like this cake is close to baked would
that be appropriate to say with gilmore
we're assuming healthy and common um
into form
with judon looking terrific what would
you say about that side of the ball yeah
they're they're gonna have
some issues on the back end right now
because
you know i'm not sure jalen mills
is anywhere close to 50 percent of what
stephon gilmore is
jc jackson's been outstanding
um the safety play is excellent but we
saw some tight end feasting by the
eagles on monday and tuesday in the red
zone so
it's it's not a way up but judon's a
great ad and having high tower viennoise
juwan bentley winovich boucher
and i'm not gonna go through all the
defensive linemen they've added that
they have but they are stocked in the
front seven so they're gonna be
miles better than they were last year
when they were actually not good at all
well then i should ask you also an
eagle's question so you said hurts
looked like the best quarterback looks
like he's ready to
to take the reins there in philly right
and you saw smith yeah did you see any
of smith because he looked terrific last
night when he had space ball in hand and
things like that i'll give you the floor
he's so sudden um but i was surprised to
see the patriots kind of languishing six
foot three corner joanna williams stick
with smith early on a couple of routes
but
and i think that smith
he's he's ridiculously fast
but
until
you know he gets through that those
first hits
i don't think his hands were great last
night he acknowledged that a little bit
after the game but hurts his
hurts was
he might have a little russell wilson in
him uh-huh
uh-huh i enjoyed him this week he threw
so accurately did you get to speak with
him because he's pretty special on that
front too
did not i was taken out cam
and how was he how's he taking this
whole business he didn't he didn't love
it
when i asked him about his instagram
post last week and how come he put that
up about
i'm not perfect but i deserve loyalty
what does that mean what do you what do
you mean there i mean you're playing
football like you sat down last week and
fans cheered on your replacement and
what do you mean there and he said no i
had nothing to do with football well
you're a professional quarterback and
that's why you have so many followers
you probably know the day after a
preseason game if you put that out there
most people are going to do that
did you say that
okay
i said well you know people were going
to take it that way he goes did i
like well kind of you did
well i put a lot of stuff on my
instagram that has nothing to do with
football
but if you do a quick perusal of his
instagram
79 percent of the posts are about
football so
i don't know how could you make it out
over the weird font
oh my gosh it's you know what man i i i
go you know
he he's been in this league 10 years now
i mean this is it and and um
and the question is is he gonna get the
opportunity to to become
the entertainer and icon that he was an
iconic play in 2015 and are those days
totally done
and and will he get the opportunity
to perform you know if he performs in in
the first three games this year like he
did last year and continued on for a
half a season and then then the
conversation will be you know
why would you go to mac i mean like
that's his best case scenario right
that's cam's
best scenario here this year his best
case scenario i think actually would
have been for mac jones to come in
and play like jared stidham
like somebody who was i think that's
happening unequipped to start i mean
he's being beaten out
that's that's the issue and if he's
being beaten out
by somebody who's never played in the
nfl before
then
it's hard for that what i think is
interesting is
the cam newton that we've seen
for 18 months or 15 months or however
long it's been
feels different than the guy who was the
mvp he's just so at ease and comfortable
and introspective and communicative
and
you know i've read enough about him in
carolina and i i know the bristling over
the way he carried himself there but
there is
no artifice to him here he is who he is
who he is
and he's constantly optimistic and
joyful i just don't think that this cam
newton is ever going to
dovetail with
an outstanding on-field cam newton
he's
he's a journeyman level thrower
and a great leader
i mean bill loves him though sorry bill
loves him though right i mean bill does
i love him too right now somebody wants
someone said you know bill loved
wes welker at three million dollars it
was when he franchised him for nine
million that he didn't really like
and the same thing is true of cam newton
at four or five million dollars
to allow himself to be benched three
times last year and never say
a sad word about it
of course he's gonna love him he's been
nothing but a pleasure to work with
because he's been easy
tom appreciate the chat this is great
man uh best of luck over the next three
weeks our eyes and ears will be peeled
and listening to the ground to hear this
theater that we just gamed out for
everybody on the rich eisen show of you
and the rest of the new england media
trying to get out of bill belichick his
thought process on his starting
quarterback and who it's going to be
prior to week one i can't wait this is
good stuff i know i got much yeah well
that makes one of us
take care tom you're the best take care
you'd be well that's tom curran
tom econ tommy
on twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here